[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive tonight we've
got the political editor of the sun
harry cole and senior associate editor
the new statesman rachel cunn live with
us until just before midnight there they
are so let's see what's on some of those
front pages
killed for kicks the latest disturbing
evidence of apparent russian war crimes
coming out of ukraine is the lead in the
metro which pictures the mayor of one
town who was killed and dumped in a mass
grave along with her husband and her son
as a result says the times britain is
demanding even tougher sanctions on
vladimir putin's regime
but the eye reports that european powers
are split over how to put further
economic pressure on russia to stop the
war
the financial times says france is
pushing for a ban on all russian coal
and oil as america calls for a trial
over war crimes in ukraine
climate change leads the guardian with
the latest warning from scientists that
it's now or never to act to stave off a
global disaster
the news that the government is planning
to privatize the tv company channel for
that's the top story in the telegraph
the mail has what it calls a huge boost
for women's rights with news that gyms
hospitals and shops will in the future
be able to offer single-sex services
such as toilets and changing rooms
the pre-easter chaos at ports and
airports is on the front of the star
with the headline wish we weren't here
and the sun pays tribute to eastenders
actress june brown who played dot cotton
for over three decades and has died at
the age of 95.
and a reminder by scanning the qr code
you see on your screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us
and as i was saying joined tonight by
harry cole and rachel come live harry
and rachel good evening to you both
thank you so much for chatting through
the papers with us let's start with the
eyes shall we and really
the story that's captured most of the
media for the past 24 hours also harry
do you want to talk us through what
they're saying and why they say europe
is split on funding putin's war
following these claims of
war crimes in butcher
yeah it's been one of those
96 hours really where you've tried to
focus
attention elsewhere you know write
stories about channel 4 and and climate
change and energy strategies and you
just can't escape out the corner of
those horrific images on the television
screens and across the internet across
the front pages tomorrow of the
horrific
trail of devastation that they're
fleeing russian troops have left in
their in their wake
and while those images are coming out of
ukraine are deeply shocking
there's an underlying fear around them
that this is just one small retreat from
one town that a large large amount of
these uh images are coming from and
makes you sort of shudder to think
what's going on in other parts of
ukraine where the russian troops are
continuing their um
occupation especially america where
there haven't been uh
cameras or journalists or tv tv crews
really able to get anywhere near it in
any meaningful way for for some weeks
now because of that horrific shelling
and bombardment and i think this might
just be the tip of an iceberg of putin's
horrific war crimes it's good to see the
world sort of catching up on calls to
you know i think
i think people will be quite sympathetic
well sympathetic to slightly more than
just putting computing in the dock um
perhaps calls or even for either the
worst reputation retribution than that
but are they catching up though because
if you look at the front of the eye they
say that europe is split on funding
putin's war and that's key isn't it is
that he's still earning huge amounts of
money every day
from these payments for oil and gas
rachel what do you think
well it's those two
uh newslines isn't it one is the the
horrific images that harry was was was
talking about and the the growing
realization of exactly what it is that
russian troops have been doing in in the
places that they've occupied um
and have now withdrawn from and then
akin to that is what is the west going
to do about it and uh particularly what
is europe going to do about it so
immense pressure on france and germany
in particular to be tougher on sanctions
the line coming from the ukrainian
president zelinski but also from the uk
that uh
putin's war machine is being funded
directly by
oil and gas revenues uh paid for by both
france and germany now um before the war
germany's
imported 55 percent of its gas from
russia france in ports 20 of its gas we
are we were in the middle of an energy
crisis even before the the russian
invasion prices are spiking
across across the world when it comes to
energy prices so you can understand a
certain reluctance on the part of the
european leaders to make life even
harder for their citizens
unfortunately that reluctance has a cost
and that cost
really it could be could be seen in in
uh the prolonging the the this conflict
um and i think very very emotive
language from from zelinski uh earlier
saying inviting
angela merkel
and nicolas sarkozy the the former
leaders of france and germany to come
and see what has happened in butcher
and to see evidence of these war crimes
as a direct result of their policy of
putin appeasement uh over the last 14
years
the front of the times britain calling
for tougher sanctions on russia liz
trust has said that we need a new wave
of sanctions harry one could argue
or one could ask the question why are we
already not imposing the toughest
sanctions that we possibly can
it's a very good point um they're
they're very much easy it is literally
cutting one's nose off to despite one's
spike one's enemies you might say there
is a next level you could go to which
complete economic isolation of russia um
that's almost a sort of uh
it is the sort of thing that
one country alone cannot do it has to be
done completely uh united or it will not
work at all and there's a real feeling
in europe actually that germany have
talked a good game so far they they came
out the traps at the beginning of this
conflict they tore up their
long-standing um constitutional rules on
on a on uh military aid and cancelled
the nordstrom 2 project even though the
fact that us would have probably
cancelled it for them
if they had not had the choice with
sanctions on it um but that seems to be
a bit of backsliding now and the the
west has been remarkably united
so far in the response to putin's
invasion but that is beginning to creak
now and you've got the polls the polish
government have launched an astonishing
attack on president macron today saying
why are you still on the phone to putin
all the time would you have negotiated
with hitler you know a very deliberate
jarring reference there to french
history
and saying the same to germany
directly pointing the finger at germany
and saying look you are not you are the
you are the roadblock they said to
further sanctions so
i think it's important that that's the
nato alliance and the in the western
alliance tries to stay united but within
the eu those tensions are really
starting to fray now
let's let's bring up the uh the front of
the times and this picture of zelensky
and
it's heartbreaking seeing his reaction
but you know our teams have been into
butcher and filmed first-hand
these pictures that we can't even show
really
russia
zalensky is saying has committed
genocide that's what zelensky is saying
right but rachel what what happens next
you know
so if we collect evidence and it's taken
to the icc but will people actually be
held to account and have they in the
past
well i think there are two questions
there there is what do we do now or what
can the west do now
and then the second question is when all
this is over
what are the consequences going to be
for putin for the russian government uh
and for those who who committed these
war crimes i think we're a bit far away
from that now that the focus for
everyone is
trying to bring an end to this conflict
but there's an interesting point that
kind of links to that and links to the
argument about sanctions and why aren't
we doing more and why aren't they more
effective which is sanctions are kind of
only half of it um putin is is is not
particularly interested in in
the sanctions uh as long as he is able
to continue with this what he is
interested in is that the votes and the
opinions of the russian people and i
think we need to remember that there is
a
parallel war going on in russia itself
which is a war of misinformation and
russia's response to the horrific
pictures we've seen is that they've
they've all been staged and that the
entire thing has been made up by ukraine
which is horrific in itself but people
in russia do believe that that's what
they're being shown every day on their
tv screens
very telling detail in the reports from
butcher that um the the soldiers there
who are the russian soldiers who are
exhausted and demoralized are for
fighting a war that they didn't
necessarily think they were going to be
fighting when they set out but going
from house to house asking what the
nazis are this narrative that putin has
sort of constructed for himself and for
the russian people that this isn't an
invasion this is russia defending itself
against the phantom menace of nazis
which
which doesn't exist in ukraine but that
is the narrative and the narrative is
one that the russian soldiers believe
it's one that many of the russian people
believe
and as long as they keep believing that
and keep supporting putin he has a very
clear reason to continue with this
violence and one that um is reflected or
that mindset of the russian troops is
reflected on the front of the metro
isn't it harry killed for kicks they say
yeah you can you can blame putin for
this and and everyone will and this
invasion was horrific but it's hard to
escape the fact that every single
invading russian force in history has
done this to the every single land that
it that it has invaded the echoes of the
polish invasion
massacre
you know this dates back this tactic
this horrific
uh
behavior sadly is nothing new and yes we
can get ahead of ourselves but it needs
to be documented there was a time when
milosevic looked like he was never going
was never going to be brought to justice
radar van karevich ended up in the hague
this can be done but the evidence needs
to be collected now uh yes you know more
more than a task force of evidence
collectors needs to be sent from the
european union and from britain and from
america but it is very important that
it's done properly because that case
does need to be made because these
people need to be brought to justice and
it will make it take years and decades
possibly but this is a sort of attack on
humanity that could not be allowed to
pass but sadly one that we've seen so
many times before harry let's start with
the guardian this ipcc report a damning
report that on any other day would make
the front of
all the papers wouldn't it harry
um
maybe
or not kind of like i mean
they sort of slightly have heard this
one before haven't we i know that i
think the the the fact that cop was
hosted by the uk last year slightly
amplified you know every single
utterance of the un but at a time when
people are struggling with energy bills
working out how they're you know going
to keep the lights on choosing between
heating and eating the shocking reports
we had today about people unable to even
afford to take food from a food bank
that requires heating you're just saying
you know pick your moments pick your
battles there is a discussion to be had
about energy but you know when the
clowns start gluing themselves to oil
refineries potentially you know but
saying that we should uh abandon oil
overnight when you know to do so but if
we have to do something about it don't
you think yes of course we do but like
yes we do but we are on a course a
transition to being carbon neutral by
2050
and i just think you know
just pick your moments there are bigger
things to fry today uh right now in
people's minds than uh than yet another
same old report from the um which says
exactly the same thing as the um report
they said three months ago and the one
we wrote three months before that we get
it look we're listening everyone's
paying attention but let's hectoring
people about the use of fossil fuels
which is you know at the moment when it
is almost like
the last thing they want is a lecture
while trying to keep themselves warm i
think is a little bit tinied okay we
don't have enough time to um to get into
that because i really want to um talk
about
who we've lost today rachel dot she was
on honey send us for 35 years and she
left us 95 years old she was
she joined five months after it launched
eastenders launch which i i wasn't aware
of i used to watch it as a teenager my
mom absolutely hated that me and my
sister watched it was our form of
teenage rebellion um and and even then
like she i i remember noticing that she
was just a phenomenal actress um and the
the what she was able the complex themes
that she was able to communicate and
portray and talk about uh on that show
the fact that she managed to do
was able to do an entire episode just
just her
which i think is a first in soap history
i think she's got a bath denomination
for that um
an absolute institution on our screens